je pense que nous et le mariage
homosexuel a été une erreur je maintiens
maintenant
est ce que est ce qu'il faut revenir là
dessus et ce qu'il faut ouvrir le sujet
j'en suis pas sûr même si c'est à
l'origine de tout au tout la suite voilà
moi je pense qu'il faut maintenant
mettre des barrières en tout cas pour
que l'on n'ait pas cette suite et qu'on
n'est pas par exemple ce qui a été voté
récemment la pma sans père voilà c'est
tout merci ludo vignes de la rochère
d'être avec nous vous êtes présidente de
la manif pour tous et d'ailleurs je
viens d'apprendre un truc c'est que
ludovic c'est le féminin de ludovic et
je savais pas merci le domaine parce que
voilà avoir pris simplement merci
beaucoup à partir
alors c'est vrai que ça a été des mots
qui ont fait extrêmement mal c était
très d'eric zemmour alors s'il vous
plaît vous êtes ouzou petitement carte
est ce que comprenez vous que certains
puissent remettre en cause le mariage
homosexuel ludo vinh vous êtes d'accord
avec les propos d'eric zemmour alors que
je crois qu'il est ample et le terme d'
erreur qui n'est pas le terme que
j'aurais employés c'est un sujet très
grave très important je pense que à
l'époque françois hollande
avait des raisons électoralistes et puis
c'était un projet qui était évidemment
plein de bonnes intentions mais je pense
que les conséquences n'ont pas été
pesées et qu'elles sont immenses pour
les enfants et j'ajouterai une autre
chose c'est plus parler de mariage
homosexuel pour ma part je n'ai jamais
parlé de mariage homosexuel la question
n'est pas la sexualité moi je parle de
mariage des personnes de même sexe
d'accord jusque 2 hommes ou 2 femmes et
bien cela signifie le mariage ouvre à la
filiation aujourd'hui on en est à la pma
son père on risque d'arriver à la gpa
qui est sur la table qui est une
pratique très grave
et la question c'est donc pour les
enfants pour les prive d'un père ou
d'une mère est implantée une mère c'est
fondamental alors lui envient je vois
beaucoup beaucoup de monde au liquor
hocher la tête là ils sont allés voir le
mariage homosexuel alors c'est
formidable c'est nouveau je suis opposé
au mariage pour les personnes de même
sexe en tout cas c'est la sexualité
débridée claire as avec moi c'est très
très clairs la sexualité des personnes
n'est pas le sujet c'est ben si c'est
toi on est de dire madame ce qui importe
c'est que le mariage entre à la
filiation si vous allez si vous êtes
sans parler de filiation
les mots sexuelle deux hommes deux
femmes qui s'épousent vous êtes pour
contrer les conti suis opposé parce que
ça implique la peur vous changez donc ça
servirait minutes la cmh en terre et la
gestation pour autrui parce que ce sont
deux hommes deux femmes et la
procréation médicalement assistée son
père qui vient d'être légalisé mais
c'est une injustice incroyable d'abord
pour les pères parce que messieurs vous
qui avez des enfants qui auraient des
enfants vous est important pour vos
enfants oui vraiment on ne peut pas dire
qu'à percer à no dice et second degré et
n'a manqué lèvres il m'a manqué elle
avait un enfant seul c'est important non
plus ça arrive mais on n'ose à
l'envahisseur
malheureusement il ya des hommes qui
partent en effet ou du conte qui
démissionnent parfois de mer mais c'est
un peu plus rare et c'est très
dommageable très regrettable pour les
enfants est en tout cas il semble malgré
tout en général qui est leur père là
c'est vraiment l'absence complète et
totale et de la décision de l'adulte
alors l'adulte il a un désir d'enfant
que j'entends mais les besoins de
l'enfant ils doivent primer c'est
essentiel en fait quelle injustice pour
lier aux gens dont moi je pense qu'être
contre le mariage homosexuel c'est faire
preuve d'homophobie au sens propre du
terme homophobie la peur de
l'homosexualité sert qu'on a peur que
s'il existe un modèle qui unissent deux
hommes ensemble ou deux femmes ensemble
que le reste de la population soit
contaminée comme si c'était une maladie
assez facile vous parler des enfants
vous avez peur que les enfants aient un
modèle ça fuse les influentes et même si
c'était une maladie et moi ce qui me
fait encore plus peur c'est qu'eric
zemmour soit si haut dans les sondages
avec ce type d'idées dégueulasse mais
alors attendez on peut revenir on peut
venir à l'appeler ticker excès de mort
après mais ça c'est votre fantasme vous
pensez que je pense que mercy de l'epr
de poids pour les enfants âgés
aujourd'hui mais d'être privés
volontairement dans papa ou de maman
mais pardon mes essayages et cela c'est
la gpa vous avez de christophe beaugrand
qui fait la promotion de la gpa avec son
livre fils à papa c'est un petit garçon
qui n'a pas tout petit garçon qui n'a
pas maîtrisé
tu t'en fous privé d'une mère qu'est ce
que rené vous plaît alors un mathieu qui
écrira train des ces mariages pour tout
j'aime pas le seul facteur mais aussi au
mariage homosexuel moi j'aime bien le
mariage mariage pour tous comme terre
moi je veux même pas me fâcher avec
madame parce que c'est je pense qu'il
faut et pardon madame vous avez besoin
comme certains d'être éduqués plus que
de créer de la polémique et de
l'engueulade parce que évidemment vous
vous dit des bêtises d'abord refuser le
mariage homosexuel c'est nier toute une
population qui existent que vous le
vouliez ou pas et qui n'est pas plus mal
et où au mieux que vous et ghinzu qui
tient les mêmes droits que vous vend et
mensonger de journée
madame vous parler pour eux vous n'en
savez rien vous ne savez pas comment
parler est la seule chose dont a besoin
un enfant pardon d'être un petit peu
c'est d'amour
il n'y a pas beaucoup sont très heureuse
aux enfants de bon goût il n'y a pas
d'enfant sans un père et une mère mais
cet homme et cette femme l'enfant tous
les êtres humains ont besoin de
connaître leurs noms n'avaient et je
finis regardez la généalogie tourner va
faire des tests de généalogie de l'adn
on a tous besoin c'est profondément
humain de savoir d'où vient la
psychogénéalogie d'ailleurs a aussi une
très grande amie madar est grande et l'
oblique des bêtises sur les gp à la
place il ya deux bêtises je vous en prie
c'est votre avis et moi je vous parle de
l'expérience de tout le même débat
l'expérience de temps d'homosexuels
gênant de voir les connaissent si
souvent le père ou la mère la mère
porteuse ou la merd donneuse qui vont
même numéro 10 ans il passe de noël en
êtes-vous trouvé formidable l'aliénation
des femmes avec les mères porteuses par
les mères porteuses vous voulez dire
n'importe quoi madame
canada les femmes le font totalement
gratuitement parce qu'elles veulent
donner la vie parce qu'elle ne le verrez
vous dites sont en train de vouloir
légaliser la gpa commercial parce que
quand parce que les mères porteuses sont
des femmes pauvres des femmes en
difficulté
vous dites n'importe quoi vous l'aviez
le pire c'est que du coup vous direz
vous on est on est on ça devient chiant
bel et bien mais j'entends c'est la fin
d'un rêve vraiment votre propos vous
mettez au coeur de votre réflexion
l'enfant c'est ça aussi je la mets au
coeur de ma réflexion et on diverge
parce que là vous nous dites en gros ces
enfants seront à priori et quoi qu'il
advienne malheureux et moi je pense que
ces enfants sont heureux pour quelles
raisons partout je ne sentais mais non
c'est pas une question de ces pas une
théorie moi je vais pas en théorie je
vis dans la pratique et dans la pratique
aujourd'hui recul et on a des enfants
sont aujourd'hui des adolescents voire
même des jeunes gens qui aujourd'hui
témoigne et qui disent je suis bien dans
mes pompes ne parlait pas à m'appeler
rassemblé les témoignages d'enfants
qu'ils n'ont pas super existe puis de
même gouffre et
dégonfler dans des couples hétérosexuels
des enfants hak'x qui aurait pris
l'exemple de christophe beaugrand non
mais je vous donne raison d'une chaussée
évidemment
c'est facile non mais je parle tout
simplement une chose qui est tout simple
il n'y a pas de droit à l'enfant
l'enfant vient nécessairement d'un homme
et d'une femme ça vous dérange savoure
mais c'est comme ça et cet homme et
cette femme tous les êtres humains tous
les enfants du monde ont besoin de les
connaître et une semaine d'ailleurs dans
la convention des droits de l'enfant le
droit de les connaître et dans la mesure
du possible évidemment ça n'est pas
toujours possible le droit d'être élevé
par eux et là on piétine tout ça c'est
si facile de ne pas s'en tenir comme on
tient des prétendues études le ccn le
comité d'éthique dit lui même que en
réalité ces études sont toutes bien
alors on va le voir revenir à l'écriture
lui donnait une exploitation des femmes
pauvres c'est tellement scandaleux c'est
le sens même du sexisme on revient donc
sur la déclaration d'eric zemmour qui
dit que le mariage pour nous c'est une
erreur gilles verdez moi c'est l'un des
meilleurs avec nous je suis pas du tout
d'accord et ce qui me choque dans les
propos d'eric zemmour est chez vous
aussi madame c'est que là on est en
train d'écouter quelqu'un eric zemmour
ou vous qui servent des discours pour
les catholiques ultras traditionnels
c'est bon ça vient sur le tapis ça
s'allume en tout cas quelque part on
sait ce que je pense à yann bell c'est
une souffrance
que tu as fini très justement est ce la
finir c'est toujours cette espèce de
nouvelles accusations systématiques
moi je suis une catholique et ses îles
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça mais ils ont
en revanche madame je suis entièrement
d'accord pour le mariage homosexuel ce
qui me gêne dans ce genre là même c'est
bien qu'elle le dise isabelle bravo les
jeunes et qu'ils disent que c'est de la
folie que fini par penser que
effectivement c'est un modèle fascistes
voire rétrograde de vouloir un homme une
femme pour un enfant ça je suis pas
d'accord maintenant s'il s'est dit
autrement que c'était parce que j'en ai
besoin de femmes c'est une évidence mais
arrête de mêlée et catholiques tout
temps à ça
peu d'énervés
mais une chose est sûre ils n'iront pas
la messe ensemble
soit bien avec avec eric zemmour la
seule chose qui soit bien qu'eric
zemmour sur ce sujet c'est comment ils
n'avancent pas masqués bah oui oui ça au
moins les gens en 2012 il le disait
disaient
catholiques fachos lt crise
traditionalistes c'est de la caricature
qui leur est servie de la réflexion est
juste de dire que pour de la stratégie
de votre phrase de débuts comme ça ça va
venir dîner
ce qui me choque c'est vous madame et
chez eric zemmour c'est que pour de la
stratégie politique qui nous sert un
discours de catholiques ultras
traditionalistes
[Rires]
finir le dôme qui fracturent une société
française déjà fissuré pourquoi remettre
ça sur le tapis parce que lui-même dit
après glaçant il faudra pas le changer
il dit ça uniquement pour capter les
entend plus parler du passé
ça franchement cet argument où on y sur
le thème là on est sur le truc ceci oui
c'est vrai mais non mais oui mais non ça
à côté de la plaque excusez moi alors je
voudrais quand même beaucoup mais je
trouve que ça à côté de la plaque qui
dis pas ça pour ça ils le pensent
vraiment arrêter de dire des conneries
c'est très grave voilà rocheman gilles
excusez moi mais j'ai eu le département
a dit il le pensait
en
électorale oui assure cyril hanouna
quand il ya un million de personnes dans
la rue j'ai cru que tu avec ma prof de
biologie
ce que ça fait 1 million amis du rugby
déjà ce que ça fait un mélange des pas
sur mon combat est mignon personnes est
venue dans la rue ça représente une
diversité ça représente tous les genres
et tous les styles et c'est parce que
vous avez en tête de manière
caricaturale simpliste est simplissime
telle ou telle catégorie de la
population et ça c'est quand on a pas
d'argument riendeau très bien mais
est-ce qu'on peut revenir à la simec
politique parce que vous êtes alors
l'aspect politique non je me sens un peu
mal nommé monsieur évoqué le fait que
zemmour eric et nous direz cela et que
j'en serai dupe alors ça c'est le granth
legrand la grande théorie depuis
quelques jours il y aurait un
rapprochement la manif pour tous eric
zemmour oui alors là dans les simplismes
et dans les amalgames c'est absolument
extraordinaire la famille tout
simplement c'est un sujet qui est
bankable
c'est un sujet et ses 18 millions de
familles en france nous avons tous
savaient pas voir un enfant heureux avec
deux personnes du même sexe que un
enfant malheureux peut-être avec de
pinceau et iliad et les regarder comme
ceux qui vont mal partout alors oui
alors que deux ils vont bien
cyril vous savez ce qu'il met la tête
mais que dit madame je suis contre le
mariage parce que y'a la filiation
gnagnan enlever la filiation parce que
si on disait ok la gpa les pma c'est
interdit pour les homosexuels et
uniquement le mariage autorisé mais
madame serait bien mal parce qu'elle est
contre le mariage tout court entre deux
hommes ou entre deux grammes et l'enfant
l'enfant c'est une excuse
mob et madame et somocer dans les moins
bons résultats
et vous vous servez des enfants des
enfants pour nasri nôtre nous obligés de
tout madame c'est toi c'est en ça c'est
quand on veut faire la victime est alors
soyons très clairs une union avec un
couple de même sexe un couple homosexuel
qui est uni ne me pose aucun problème
le mariage c'est simplement la filiation
il ya une filiation possible en dehors
du mariage mais si vous avez déjà été un
mariage à la mairie qu'est-ce que de
quoi on parle on lit les articles du
code civil qui parle des enfants à venir
et tout le sujet est là mais c'est vous
qu'êtes sexiste d'un cordon se marier
qu'on est une femme c'est par ces mois
pour pondre c'est pour faire des enfants
n'a pas forcément posée alors ils
pensent qu'on peut se marier c'est quoi
sinon ce que vous dites mais le
maquillage je regrette c'est le tout
jeune ariane j'adore à des enfants est
ce que vous dites là le mariage à nantes
rennes la filiation il yal'esprit
hommage en voulant comme ça je peux
vouloir donc avoir
généralisé nom dont le mag dont la loi
le mariage à 100 vous voyez bien que
c'est d'une part le mariage des
personnes de même sexe on vient d'avoir
la légalisation de la pma s'empêtre est
encore une forme va priver pour toujours
faire volontairement les enfants
orphelins de père et on a déjà la
revendication des mères porteuses qui
est sur la table des femmes qu'on va
réduire à lutter à leur rupture est ce
qu'on va louer et une fois la fin de la
grossesse on les a sélectionnés sur
catalogue et hydra et à la fin de la
grossesse on vient prendre leurs enfants
contre une rémunération
mais ces moments là
moi je peux t'entraîner c'est la suite
c'est une très belle
vous ne concevez pas qu effectivement un
enfant ce n'est pas le fruit de deux
personnes de même sexe à la limite mais
bon votre discours c'est un discours de
génétique presque c'est un homme une
femme mais on est en 2001 terre madame
je comprends pas ce qu'elle pleure moi
j'ai des enfants j'en ai 4 j'aurais pas
pu avoir d'enfants jeunes en effet d'une
autre façon ce qui compte pour un enfant
c'est pas d'où ils viennent c'est
comment ils sont voulus chose et moi
j'ai plein d'amis et d'amants eux qui
ont comme en qui on fait des enfants qui
ont décidé d'avoir un enfant bien que la
volonté farouche d'avoir un enfant de
ces deux là elle vaut bien celle de deux
hommes et une femme et ce qui compte
pour un enfant et j'en ai 4 c'est pas
d'où viennent ces leur amour et l'amour
qu'on leur donne est votre définition le
scénario j'ai fini venir des secours il
est rétrogradé je suis désolé je rejoins
mon camarade de l'emmo vous avez un
discours excusez moi qui encourage une
seule chose en ce pays tout en a pas
besoin l'homo ces signes d'un
côté ce qui vous dérange c'est ça y'a
que sa
loi comme la pema son père qui prive des
enfants père ne sera jamais une loi
d'amour mais quand on démarre le but
visé les choses la raison ces éléments
de langage absolument bidon l'amour ça
se serait su répliquer céréales amour de
la religion partout et je sais bien être
du jury c'est monsieur qui parle de
coluche et vous avez dit une relation
d'amour je vais parler de religion la
loire layon sur mes relations d'amour
une loi qui prive volontairement des
enfants notamment ne sera de père ne
sera jamais une loi d'amour mais
maintenant le désert était de dire qu'à
voir ses marques l'auteur se marie c'est
pour avoir des enfants hétéro ou homo
arrêté vers l'euro d'une femme c'est pas
forcément d'avoir un enfant elle sait
pas de mettre bas fait pas une vache
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes favorable à la gpa dans la gpa
on prend les ovocytes une femme qu'on a
choisis sur catalogue on prélève contre
rémunération les les ovocytes ces deux
prélèvements c'est de ces deux-là delà
de l'exploitation reproductive on les a
et on un séminaire une femme on utilise
comme une incubatrice on sait comment ça
on y donne des contrats incroyable
[Applaudissements]
non mais sans déconner cette médecine se
mobilisent non mais attendez c'est
facile de finir à ben oui mais bon mieux
en rire madame
j'ai pris un très bon leur semble on le
sait mine avec un embryon learning qui
n'est pas d'elle puisque on a pris des
officiers de quelqu'un on le sait mines
on l'a fait porter pendant neuf mois à
la naissance et la naissance est un
événement immense la maternité c'est un
événement incroyable et on retire
définitivement cet enfant à la femme et
on retire cette sa mère à cet enfant
pour toujours mais excusez moi en
matière de pratique vétérinaire je pense
que la gpa ont fait pas pire et en cas
de sexisme en termes de sexisme c'est le
summum de l'exploitation de la femme et
de l'aliénation et de l'invisibilisation
de la femme d'ailleurs une partie des
féministes heureusement est logiquement
s'y opposent en revanche les écolos
annoncé que l'on ne voit aucun problème
à la partie trop loin cela
n'alimente pas jeu